each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright we're going to start the session
this afternoon sessions so welcome
everybody welcome to the semantic
computing theme of the party software
summit so in this theme this is a theme
where we already acknowledged that data
has become a first class citizen and
what we are interested in is how can we
now start making sense of data how can
we go from data to information knowledge
and eventually intelligence to do so we
have several talks lined up this
afternoon we have a couple and tomorrow
morning to where we will be looking at
scale in the morning this afternoon
we're going to look at some influencing
and some web science technologies and
how they can bring bring us to this path
I was talking about so to start I'm
going to welcome zubeen bahaminy for the
first talk and let me give you some
introduction so first of all I noticed
that you have actually positions in
three continents which is not usual so
one of them in the u.s. United States at
Carnegie Mellon another one in South
Korea and the one where I think you
reside though most of the time is at the
University of Cambridge just across the
channel zuber nominees currency
professor of information engineering at
University of Cambridge as I just
mentioned and he drives activities in
for the machine running group and he
also coordinates cognitive systems
engineering and today he's going to talk
about probabilistic modeling and
knowledge representation Zuba thank you
okay everybody can hear me fine thank
you ebeling very much for organizing
this session it's great pleasure to be
here I'm going to talk about
probabilistic modeling and knowledge
representation and my starting point is
as eveline hinted at the idea that
data is all around us so we're really
living in an era of abundant data and in
a sense we're in an information
revolution right now data is all around
us in society the web social networks
mobile networks etc the sciences are
becoming very data intensive you have
large-scale scientific experiments
producing lots of data the business
world is relying more and more on data
to produce a commercial advantage and
all of these leads us to needing tools
for modeling searching visualizing
merging and understanding large data
sets so this is kind of the starting
point of a lot of the things that I'm
interested in and a lot of what we do is
build modeling tools in our group so our
modeling tools if we want to build them
to handle these kinds of data need to
have a few desidera one of them is that
they should be able to faithfully
represent the uncertainty in our model
structure and the parameters a noise in
our data there's a lot of data but it's
very noisy in a lot of ways our modeling
tools should be automated and adaptive
they should be robust and they should
scale well to large data sets so the
approach that we tend to take in our
community is a probabilistic modeling
approach and the basic idea is if you
ask yourself what's a model well a model
describes data that one can observe from
system whether it's a biological model
or a physical model or model of the web
or anything like that and so if we use
the mathematics of probability theory to
express all the forms of uncertainty
that we have about our model and all the
kinds of noise associated with our model
then we can use what used to be called
about a hundred years ago inverse
probability or Bayes rule and that
allows us to make inferences about
unknown quantities in our model
adapt our models and make predictions
and learn all from the data that we
observe so it allows us to invert our
model to do all these interesting things
so a lot of the work that I'm going to
talk about is based on this very simple
rule which is called Bayes rule it's a
sort of axiom of probability theory
which tells us I've written it in words
here how to convert a model remember a
model is or in this case let's call it a
hypothesis a hypothesis defines a sort
of distribution over possible data that
you could observe and you may have a
whole bunch of different hypotheses
before you observe the data so you need
to have some sort of what's called a
prior on the different hypotheses
waiting the different hypotheses by how
plausible they might be and then you
observe some data and what happens when
you observe some data is that the
weights on those hypotheses change and
this rule tells us how to go from our
prior weights on the hypotheses after we
observe the data multiplying the
probability of the data given the
hypothesis by those prior ways to obtain
what's called the posterior weights on
those hypotheses so Bayes rule is a
single rule that tells us how to do
inference about hypotheses from data and
a lot of key problems in learning and
prediction can be seen as forms of
inference so in particular in the field
of machine learning we're using Bayes
rule and a lot of other mathematical
techniques to design systems that learn
from data that try to reason and act
based on data so it's a very
interdisciplinary field and although the
term machine learning is fairly new it's
been around you know maybe since the mid
80s the idea of building intelligent
learning systems obviously has been
around a really
really long time and has lots of other
names and relates to lots of other areas
of science and mathematics and
engineering and one of the interesting
things is that you know in putting down
a list of these areas maybe the surprise
element comes from statistics so it
wouldn't have been clear maybe 50 years
ago when people who are trying to do AI
in the early days the statistics was
going to play such an important role in
this field of machine learning but
really statistics is the mathematics of
doing inference from data and so that's
why it's ended up being so prominent so
here's the canonical example from
machine learning where you're trying to
build a classifier to classify data into
two classes let's say this red class in
this blue class and let's say your
classifier is this linear boundary so
the ingredients that you have in almost
any machine learning system are some
kind of data in this case data points
with their associated labels plus or
minus one and then you have a model that
tells us for a new data point the
probability that it might belong to one
or the other class this is a very
simplistic model where the probabilities
are 1 and 0 but you could have a more
soft model in a sense and then that
model has some parameters in it this
shape of this line and where it's
located and those parameters are what
you're trying to learn from data so that
you can generalize to new data points so
our goal is to infer the unknown
parameters of our model from data so as
to be able to predict future data points
that says so that we can classify new
data points so almost everything in
probability and statistics can be
written down this is a bit of a
simplification but essentially the two
key rules that you need to do almost
anything are this sum rule and the
product rule and this just tells us the
calculus of what happens with
probability distributions
in case of the sum rule if you have a
probability distribution over two
variables if you sum or integrate over
one of the variables you get a
probability distribution over one
variable the product rule tells us if
you have a joint distribution over two
variables you can write it as a product
of this region over the first variable
called the marginal and this conditional
distribution of the second variable
given the first variable so using these
two simple rules we can actually write
down a general framework for doing all
sorts of machine learning and learning
from data and predicting building models
etc so we combine these two rules to get
Bayes rule that's where Bayes rule comes
from from these two simpler rules we
give names to different ingredients and
then we can write down how to do
prediction based on data so this is how
we predict a new data point x given a
data set that we've observed and some
model that we've assumed so this is a
probability distribution over possible
new data set the data points because we
haven't obviously observed those new
data points yet we can do model
comparison as well now one of the key
things that makes this framework
interesting is that if we have a number
of models and we have some data we can
use this framework to evaluate how
probable those models are given the data
and a nice property that the framework
has is that it automatically favors
simpler models over more complex models
so it has built in this idea that you're
there's a preference for simplicity
which is sometimes called Occam's razor
so if we're trying to compare to models
m and M prime we can write down the
probability of a model given data in in
this way as this red term being the
marginal likelihood that we're going to
focus on times the prior renormalized
and then this marginal likelihood the
probability of the data given the model
well how do we write that
just invoke the sum rule the sum rule
tells us to compute that we would need
to average or integrate or sum over all
possible parameter values that model can
have so a more complicated model
involves averaging or integrating or
summing over a higher dimensional
parameter space a simpler model might
have fewer parameters and so how does
this equation actually capture the idea
that more complicated models should be
penalized well there are several ways of
of coming to that and I've written three
different interpretations of the
marginal likelihood that capture this
idea that you prefer simplicity the
first interpretation is this expression
here tells us that it defines the
probability that randomly selected
parameters from the prior would have
generated data set D and so a more
complicated model has more flexibility
that has more possible settings of the
parameters so if you generated
parameters randomly from this prior
distribution then they're very unlikely
to generate a particular data set D
unless that complexity was really
necessary to generate the data so that's
how you can only you only really go to
more complicated hypotheses if that
complexity is necessary and couple of
other interpretations are that it's the
probability of data under the model
averaging over all possible parameter
values not tuning the parameters to give
you the best probability and you can
also interpret it from an
information-theoretic point of view as
the number of bits of surprise that
observing some data d under the model m
so this thing is measured in bits ok and
the basic consequence of this is that if
you observe a particular data set then
you can reject both models that are too
simple and too complicated for that data
set so here's an example of that in a
very simple machine learning setting
where we observe some eight data points
and we're trying to fit different
polynomials obviously if we fit a very
complicated polynomial
mapping from X to Y we can fit those
eight data points exactly but when we do
this Bayesian model selection with
Occam's razor we find that this model is
way too complicated and that simpler
hypotheses like for example that it's a
linear or quadratic are much more
probable than that it's a seventh order
polynomial okay so I don't want to talk
about that too much because I want to
really talk about representations of
knowledge and the role of probabilities
in those representations so let's talk
about the sort of role of representing
beliefs in the context of AI so imagine
you have a robot and for this robot to
behave intelligently it should really be
able to represent something about the
world that it's in maybe the location of
the power source or whether some sensor
is malfunctioning or whether it's under
threat etc now inside the brain of the
robot we need to somehow numerically
represent its beliefs in different
propositions and so imagine that we
assign a numerical value to the
strengths of those beliefs now you could
ask yourself what short what sort of
mathematics should i use to manipulate
strengths of beliefs beliefs in a robots
brain and I priori that it doesn't seem
like there should be an obvious answer
to that maybe you can do anything you
want well the interesting thing is that
if you start to say okay well I want
this mathematics for representing
strengthened believes to satisfy certain
axioms of common sense reasoning which I
won't go into great depth but they're
sort of written here on this one slide
these are called the Cox axioms things
like you want to be able to use real
numbers to represent strengths of
beliefs and you want your calculation of
beliefs to be consistent with some basic
things about common sense but it turns
out that
the this idea of a belief function the
belief in a particular proposition B of
X or for example the belief in x given
that you already know why or the joint
belief between x and y then that belief
function must satisfy the rules of
probability theory the sum and product
rule and basil and all those other
things that I talked about before so so
these rules of probability are not just
useful if we're just modeling data but
we also think that they're useful for
representing beliefs in an intelligence
system so they're also a path towards
building AI systems I think but there's
another way of deriving this framework
which is through it's called Dutch book
theorem which is something about
gambling and it's a statement about what
should you do with your beliefs if
you're a betting man or woman and the
basic idea is that assume that you're
except you're willing to accept bets
with odds proportional to the strength
of your belief so if you believe
something with strength point nine then
you would accept a bet that would give
you more than a dollar say two dollars
if X is true and night and you would
lose nine dollars of X is false
certainly that seems like a good bet if
that's your belief now if that's the
case that it turns out that unless your
beliefs again satisfy the sum rule and
the product rule in Bayes rule etc then
there is a set of bets that you'd be
willing to accept where you're
guaranteed to lose money no matter what
the outcome is in the only way for this
bedding or decision making intelligent
system to guard itself against the
so-called Dutch books is for the beliefs
of that system to satisfy the rules of
probability so again this points that
the rules of probability is being
fundamental to building intelligent
decision-making systems as well of
course this is all nice theoretically
but we have to do this in practice
in real-world systems so how do we
represent knowledge in the intelligence
system and again there are many
different ways of representing knowledge
and I'll talk about a couple of them but
i want to point in the direction of
something that's been i'd say rather
revolutionary in the field of machine
learning which is this idea that we can
use graphical models to represent a
certain form of knowledge about the
relationships between variables in
complex systems so a graphical model is
simply a graph like this in this case
this is a directed graphical model where
the nodes represent random variables and
the edges in the graph represents
statistical dependencies between the
variables and these models have appeared
now everywhere in the field of machine
learning and you might want to ask
yourself why why are these graphical
models useful what do they give us and
the answer is that there there's sort of
three reasons why graphical models have
been so successful in this field first
of all graphs are just intuitive to look
at so they seem to be an intuitive way
of representing and visualizing
relationships between many variables for
example family trees circuit diagrams
all sorts of things are written down as
graphs secondly graphs allow us to
abstract away the relationships between
variables from the inner details of the
parametric form of how those variables
interact so by writing down a graph we
are able to tell things like is a
dependent on be given that we know the
value of C without really worrying about
the details of what are the joint
probability distribution over those
things so it's a nice level of
abstraction and finally more from a
computer science point of view if you
have a graphical model representing the
relationships between all your variables
and then you want to build a system that
does some sort of inference
that figures out the probability of a
given see the probability that there's a
meltdown in the nuclear power plant
given that the temperature reads a
particular value somewhere else that if
you want to do reasoning of that kind
you can represent it in your graphical
model and compute that that form of
probabilistic reasoning by sending
messages between the nodes in the graph
so you can create a message passing
algorithm that sends messages between
these nodes and in one pass it exactly
computes the the beliefs of the graph
are more complicated cases you have to
iterate so graphical models are this
nice intersection between statistics
graph theory and computer science and
they've been very influential again in
the field of machine learning now if
you're trying to learn graphs from data
let's say you just observe masses of
data and you don't know what the
structure of the graph is then this is
actually a very hard problem because
there are super exponentially many
possible graphs that you could have for
any particular set of variables and
there's a lot of work that's gone into
structure learning on graphs and I'm
going to tell you a little bit about
some of the work that we're doing in
this area but I want to point out one
interesting thing so if you have a bunch
of variables that you've measured for
example you've measured a bunch of genes
in a whole bunch of experiments and you
want to know how they're related to each
other you can start by running one of
the standard graphical model learning
methods that are out there and it might
give you a graph but what's actually
missing from that is the fact that
you've only measured a few things and
the real world is actually a very
complicated place so there might be many
many things you haven't measured so this
concept of hidden variables things we
haven't measured will be a very
important one to for us to think about
so let's look at a particular kind of
graph which again has proved very
popular in the machine learning
world in the last few years and let's
think about how we learn the structure
of these graphs so imagine we had a
graph where at the bottom of the graph
we have some stuff that we've observed
some measurements that we have from some
sensory system or you know that we
obtained from some database somewhere
and we want to learn the relationships
between these variables by having layers
of hidden variables that tell us how
these variables are related to each
other so this first layer of hidden
variables will capture low level
correlations between the variables and
then you might have an extra layer that
captures higher level correlations etc
etc as you go up the the levels of this
graph now these kinds of graphical
models are not useful for everything ok
there they appear particularly in
problems that we might characterize as
pattern recognition problems for example
where we're trying to take images and
learn a deep structured representation
of the content of those images and in
fact these these models are really
inspired by the sorts of things that
happen in our brain if we look at the
visual system and we look multiple
layers up from that there are layers of
you could say hidden units trying to
represent what's actually out there in
the visual world but the question that
we might be interested in is given some
data can we actually learn how many
layers do we need how many hidden
variables should we have how why should
each of these layers be how should they
be connected etc so the way we're doing
this is we're applying the basic ideas
that we talked about before of course
there are a lot of details I can't talk
about here but the general idea is in a
sense very straightforward we write down
some very flexible distribution over
graphs and the parameters of those
graphs and in fact it's
no flexible that we're going to allow
ourselves infinitely many layers if we
need them and infinitely many hidden
units if we need them and we won't
represent them on the computer more than
a finite number but we allow ourselves
at least to have that flexibility then
once we write this down then given the
data we can infer the graph structure in
the parameters of the graph and again if
we apply this to things like images of
faces then we can end up with these
interesting representations of different
features of the face like mouths and
maybe nose Ridge here etc and these are
the structure of this graph has learned
completely just from just from the faces
that is observed none of this is pre
specified and you can look higher up in
the hierarchy and see what's actually
being represented at these higher levels
of the hierarchy and it's more and more
global things about these data so I'm
going to skip over representing simple
relations and talk about merging
knowledge bases which is a different
line of work that we're doing but where
we're really motivated by trying to find
a probabilistic inference solution to
the problem of merging knowledge bases
or merging oncology's so at the moment
there are many many knowledge bases that
exist out there representing all sorts
of really really interesting knowledge
and they overlap to quite an extent and
it would be absolutely wonderful to have
general methods for merging these
knowledge bases so that we can make use
of the great amount of knowledge that we
have out there in a more efficient way
so the basic motivation is there's
valuable information in disparate
knowledge bases in the form of entity
relationships if we can merge these then
that would provide billions of facts in
a very in a single place that we could
then query and there are great efforts
along these lines
for example this project on linking open
data and inspired by that sort of thing
and with a collaboration between my team
and Microsoft Research Cambridge
involving this group of people our goal
is to develop scalable and robust
probabilistic algorithms for entity and
structure matching of ontologies so I'll
go through that very quickly the test
case that we're going to look at is the
following let's merge information on
movies in IMDb an ontology that I'm sure
you're all familiar with and Yago an
ontology based on data from wikipedia
where net and geo names and so if we
start with this problem we see that
there are actually a lot of very
interesting challenges that need to be
solved along the way so I'll just go
through some of those challenges there's
a challenge in size yago has 400 million
facts IMDb has 23 million there are
different numbers of relations but
clearly IMDB is about movie and yagos
about all sorts of things so we can
limit that to the movie related part
obviously we want to do that in an
automated way but for now let's just do
it by hand and then we get more
comparable sizes here and then again we
can limit to common relations which
we've written here and now the the
scales of reverse Yago only has eight
hundred forty thousand facts IMDb has 17
million their challenges in the way the
data is represented names are
represented differently human names and
movie names their mismatches at the
concept level there needs to be
normalization by hand but again the real
challenge would be to create absolutely
automatic ways for inferring how to
normalize the text across different
different ontologies their challenges in
granularity for example in one case you
might represent the whole TV series as
one entity in the other case you would
represent four
every episode as a different entity
their challenges in different
information coverage but again that's an
opportunity we want to get greater than
the sum of the two parts by combining
these ontologies and where we've gotten
to so far in this project is that we've
managed to get a procedure that will do
exact matching of some entities and
starting from those exact matches we can
propagate the knowledge that we have in
those exact matches to be able to match
additional things in the two ontology so
the exact matching procedure gives us
about twenty percent and we need to go
the extra eighty percent or so to be
able to really do the matching so if we
represent ontology merging as a
probabilistic inference and learning
problem we see lots of problems like
inference problems everywhere that we
look here are these two entities the
same are these two relations the same
can we learn the string transformation
in an unsupervised way between how
things are represented into oncology's
given examples can we learn a good cost
function or probability model for doing
the matching of ontologies if two
ontology is disagree which one is more
reliable how do we combine the
information in that way and how do we
generally represent uncertainty about
facts in our ontology and so this is
this is what we're doing currently we're
trying to tack all these problems so to
summarize I talked about a general
framework for probabilistic modeling and
bayesian inference as two sides of the
same coin then I talked about Bayesian
machine learning in the context of
learning graphical model structures
which is one form of knowledge
representation and finally I told you
about some of the early work we've now
been doing on merging ontology as an
inference problem thanks thank you let's
thank our speaker
we probably have time for one or two
questions hi hi my name is bitterly Tina
I learned I worked many years ago on
something called multi database systems
and the devil advocates question we know
the problems the challenges that you
enumerate for last 30 years at least
what is kind of warranty that your
approach is better than thousands of
approaches that have been proposed till
now I I think that's a perfectly good
question so I'm not claiming yet that
our approach is better than anything but
I'm coming in as a machine learning
researcher who's interested in learning
and inference and in a sense discovering
the rich world that there is in merging
ontology and I hope that if we take a
fresh approach to this we might be able
to contribute something to the you know
as you say decades of literature that
that has been worked on in this area so
certainly I don't want to claim until we
have some evidence that anything that we
do is better than anything that has been
done before any other question
I John the man from the Open University
so when people do learning on the web
one the tricks they use is the fact that
you have multiple sources so you just do
a vote because there are 10,000 mentions
of where Paris is in France so do you
think that once the web of data grows
and you have multiple sources not just
comparing to the 10 or 100 or even a
thousand that your problems will some of
the problems you have will just go away
I think that certainly the more
information you have from different
sources that presents both opportunities
and challenges so the opportunities are
as you can as you say maybe you can just
vote and it will resolve the ambiguities
that you have but there are certainly
cases where simply voting is not going
to get you very far because those
sources are not independent the the idea
of voting is only really useful if that
those sources of information are
independent and the challenges are also
then the scale of the problem gets
bigger if you're matching multiple
things at the same time so we focused on
just matching two things now but clearly
matching three things simultaneously
should be somehow better because you can
do things like voting as well but we'd
like to think rather than an algorithmic
approach which just says let's vote on
something we'd like to treat that as an
inference problem where perhaps if you
know one of these sources is unreliable
and from other votes disagreeing then
you would down wait one of the sources
versus other sources and you can do all
that in fairly ad-hoc ways but you can
also do that do that by thinking about
hidden variables representing the
reliability of different sources there's
a lot of very interesting research some
of which actually from Microsoft
Research Cambridge on how to combine
different unreliable sources of
information Thank You let's thank our
speaker again
and I'm actually personally very
interested in learning what you're going
to learn the future and how this can
reply to you know when you start talking
about petabytes exabytes yeah thank you
our next speaker is Stefan stop
so from the University of koblenz so one
characteristic about you I found is that
so you are both an academic but you also
have one foot or maybe two feet in the
entrepreneurial world we don't apprised
and otherwise so Stefan stop is
Professor for databases and information
systems his interests lie in web science
and technologies for web science in
particular semantic web web retrieval
social web and multimedia Virginia web
software web and interactive web well a
lot about web so I'm assuming our scale
here thank you thanks a lot Evelyn yes
Oh was just as fun so here we go first
maybe before I start a few notes what I
talk about here is some stuff we have
done over the last five years and over
the last three years this has been shown
to work together with a lot of students
and colleagues in the most project some
people as your name here like last month
from technical university trace and
chest pan from University Aberdeen and
their teams and this was really core to
get this going here maybe what I want to
do first is to show you the kind of
overall vision that we want to produce
here by including ontology and otology
technologies into normal software
modeling and development lifecycle and
if you take a very long range
perspective what you see with software
languages is that you we started with an
type languages we added types we added
constraint language is describing what
kind of parameters are given in design
by contract for example with ontologies
and an ontology driven process you
inherit a lot of technologies especially
reasoning technologies that can give you
more power and where does this power
come from well there are different
extremes you have constrained languages
like oh CL for example and they are like
data lock you can do quite some
interesting
sitting with them but if you really want
to know more information about the
classes and the objects together about
the two different levels that you have
in your models or about three levels
that you have in your models then these
kind of constraint languages don't give
you the right power so in a way these
languages are not powerful enough on the
other hand of course you have software
verification use model logics
first-order logic this kind of thing
there and this very powerful stuff but
they don't work at that level of
efficiency that quite often need for
norms of a development project and in
between over the last 15 years we have
seen a development of ontology recent
technologies that let you work with
large models in a pragmatically feasible
way and do reasoning and do help the
software engineer and so what we see
from these new technologies that have
been developed over the last 10-15 years
is that you can do all kinds of
consistency checking with your software
Martin said we think are quite
interesting and you can not only do some
checking but you can also give some
advice as to how to improve the models
or how where the problems are with these
languages or these models now how does
it start off it started off with a
rather mundane thing we have these two
pillars here this is the ontology world
where I come from working on the
Semantic Web and and different types of
applications there and of course there
is the software modeling pillow and of
course when we have these mythologies we
also always had software code to
actually build applications and in these
applications ontologies were used and
that's of course core to the ontology
world that somehow these anthologies our
models are that are visible to the user
and interact with the software so here i
have to thank subang because he already
brought up some of them told you that
are in use here are some other ones
especially in the medical domain they're
really big anthologies that are used in
actual systems so sno-med or the
foundational model of anatomy they have
a few hundred thousands of entities in
these mythologies that means
and relationships that are there and
that are used by actual systems and well
if you go to the business to business
world you have terminologies some
project partners of mine they counted
that there are lots of some 500
terminologies they are not necessarily
yet in the owl or @f format but they
should rather be in order to improve
their management now at this point when
we developed applications that would use
these ontology I was quite frustrated
why because you had the intelligence on
one side and you had the software
development on the other side and the
bridge between these two worlds was
rather loose and it was very
inconvenient and one once you would
start developing your models on the one
on the other side you would lose the
connection between the three sides and
the software would break very easily so
I was always frustrated by having my
applications break all the time because
the autologous are continually evolving
and of course you meet this new piece of
component software component that you
include on the left hand side so then
2006 was there was a PhD student coming
in and said well you have this problem
how can we deal with that and he had the
very good idea to say well we need to
look at how the ontology technologies
fit into our software development models
so in the rest of this talk I don't talk
about how nice or big or something snow
mad or FMA are I talked about how do
these ontology technologies actually fit
into our software models and i want to
show you two examples of them without
saying that these two examples cover
everything so especially in the most
project we had a kind of staged approach
them to say well of course first we need
to look at the basic technologies that
are around on these sites so ah there
are model-driven software development
and you have a lot of different tools
you have different modeling languages
you have transformation languages and
you probably know them better than me
because I think many of you are software
engineers by but by Hardware I can
rather from the ontology site and then
in the ontology side you have reasoning
technologies description logics
reasoning which is a subset of
first-order logic and give you sound and
complete reasoning for pragmatically
large ontology worst case is always like
too bad to do anything but pragmatically
you can come up with rather big models
and still reason with them in a in a
decent time and of course also in this
project we were developing some tricks
of the trade and Jeff pan especially
wrote some very nice paper is about to
do approximations and do get a lot of
feedback correct feedback in very short
time improving available performance
even more on top of these basic
technologies that we use in order to
support intelligent rim software
development we then looked how can we
bridge between these two different
worlds and I want to look a little bit
into how does such a bridge look like
how can we do some consistency checking
and how can we then support the the
software development lifecycle and
provide some guidance with that i want
to show you two small case studies
depending on time maybe just one let's
see so the first one is about including
your ontology languages into the main
specific languages and why that well the
generic picture we have there we have
there in our case that it was we have a
user of this domain specific language
and I will show you what this domain
specific language was and is and well in
the usual sense of the main specific
languages of course the user would
develop a domain model added to vent the
main model of course would have to
correspond to the metamodel which
prescribes the abstract syntax and in
the case of our case study we had a
software company come arch from Cracow
Poland and they had software developers
who would prescribe these
domain-specific languages these
domain-specific language of course again
needs to
adhere to some meta meta modeling
languages in order to prescribe the
language below so you have the typical
metamodeling approach that you would
also have with more for example and in
our case we looked at how can this made
a modeling language that you use in
order to define your domain specific
line which look like and how can help at
this level of developing this domain
specific language with language as well
as at the level below where the dsl user
is acting in order to give some guidance
to the user and in order to ensure that
we have sufficient constraints at the
language level now why is this
interesting why is this different from
let's say having some ocl constraints in
your different models it's interesting
because the idea is that with ontology
reasoning technologies you specify these
constraints once but then you can employ
them at two and with more recent models
even at two or three layers and reason
over these different layers at the same
time without having to specify the
constraints and you while in typical OCA
constraints you would rather have for
each layer and independent set of
constraints where you would not quite
know where they fit together very easily
so what is the case study the case study
was as a set at calm arch Poland now
there are very successful in development
and selling network software
infrastructure so there's of
telecommunication providers by the
software and with the software they
claim then administrate different types
of routers you name the different
companies and they support for the
telecommunication providers these
different configurations now when you
look at the domain model what they need
is for the different types of routers
that that are supported you have these
different devices there's a lot of
flexibility in setting up this device
with having different slots different
operating system modules and different
engines
a run for this individual devices and I
must confess I'm not very good at this
domain so you can ask me a lot of
terrible questions that I cannot answer
typical restrictions that we would have
there are for example at Cisco device
having some configuration configurations
coming with some engines and you need
some stuff in order to run this device
successfully this can become quite
complicated rules and what you need the
air is you need in the end our designer
of the language that allows that gives
to the user language well the user is
easily capable of providing the right
steps into the right slots without
thinking a lot about whether it's a
formal or informal language users should
just be able to push in some slots and
get the correct feedback without
bothering a lot about what is the exact
plan but the dsl design of course he
should do a bit more work and the status
quo much was that basically they have a
very simple domain-specific language
based on XML and funny stuff of course
war step with just having XML you could
produce all kind of invalid
configurations and you would have to
develop some Java code which was not
really decorative that would then have
to check whether what you do there it
really makes sense so you could say
there was not a lot of declarative
mechanisms built into this domain
specific language mechanism here you see
a few more of the things that a user
should have from such models so the user
should be able to configure something
and say well I need such a hot swappable
osm and but then of course this may be
problematic there may be an
inconsistency and of course that should
be signaled the interesting thing here
is such as signaling should be come
early the good thing about ontology
reasoning technologies here is that you
can reason about partial knowledge so
when you recognize that there is a
configuration that's not completed yet
but that's already inconsistent you can
discover this but you don't have to
prescribe exactly what are all pause
all combinations that could eventually
become inconsistent you really just have
your domain model and if there is an
inconsistent showing up early the reason
that finds that so that's nice because
then you can signal the user here's a
problem and maybe just another side note
here it's of course also an interesting
capability because it's a capability
where users of this web ontology
language often get confused about it's
called the open world model and people
don't like that very much they don't
understand what open world is which is a
closed world as the logicians call it
but if you call it to these technicians
say well that's a model that you're
currently drafting versus that's a model
that you then will deploy they
understand that these model that you
draft behaves differently in its
different consistency requirements then
a model that you deploy and the reason
it naturally supports this distinction
between drafting and deploying a model
so what are these requirements that the
user has well checking debugging such
models then of course what you needed
here in order to become consistent you
need first some slots into this
configuration then you can insert
hot-swappable osm and you can even
suggest to the user what's now possible
to insert here so he doesn't have to to
look around a lot and then of course you
can add things and again there may be
inconsistencies may be here because you
don't have a specific card insert it and
there the reasoning can suggest to you
that there is a specific configuration
that does not follow the model that you
require in the background so in this
sense here you come up with explanations
and hopefully at the end the user comes
up with a consistent configuration where
you can specify in more detail what the
user has exactly configured configured
without giving all the details namely
such a cisco 7600 three device now you
could say well isn't that the kind of
expert systems we have 30 years ago in a
way you said you could say well to some
extent yes because it's offering the
kind of capabilities the quite a mother
extent no because now I want to show you
a bit how this is developed by how much
now
using the framework and not looking at
exactly what is the exact procedural
knows that I need to build in but rather
how should the software must look like
in all that I get this kind of behavior
and that's a core quite a different
twist to producing the same kind of
capabilities with less work okay now I
want to show you a little bit code not
sure whether that's appropriate here for
this kind of talk but I thought I'd
rather show something very concrete so
you know what's going on so here you
have the domain-specific language that's
what what come arch is using now and
well it's it's not very unusual it
explains some of these devices and how
they fit together now the idea was that
we extend the domain-specific language
that they almost use structurally at
least with some of the capabilities that
description logics reasoning on told you
we think technologies offer so that's
the piece in red that you see here what
you do here is you describe what are the
features that should be fulfilled such
that an object belongs to a certain
class that's basically so it's not very
different than the normal conceptual
modeling you do it say in your mail
class diagram the only difference being
that the capabilities you have here are
more powerful from the reasoning site so
you could even go and say I take an
email class diagram and push this into
the reasoning engine and already there
you may get warnings inconsistencies and
so on and people do this and can work
with that of course if you make the
language a little bit more powerful you
can express more constraints on your
domain specific language so the domain
specific language that's craft here has
these ontological restrictions now here
you see this on this the upper right
corner that's the top of the dsl
designer that means it's not a matter to
the user to understand while these
restrictions on the classes where they
mean user in the end should only just
know
there's a nice buttons that you can push
and it gets an explanation of when
things go wrong and not more now
description logics which corresponds to
this red part as a subset of first or
logics gives you reasoning at two levels
so you can reason now about this
language that is crafted here whether it
is consistent in itself or whether you
defined a language or whether you define
a lang the piece in the language that
you cannot instantiate with violating
the models so you get some notion of
consistency of your domain specific
language directly for the dsl designer
that's depicted here in the upper right
corner and then you get reasoning at
this object level for the user uses this
language in order to fill in specific
slots it sounded complete reasoning if
you want to speed up you can of course
say okay I'm only interested in some
approximation quite often is also useful
it's pragmatical efficient some of these
ontologies with several hundreds of
thousands of concepts they need a very
long time to reason about but that's not
quite surprising given that they have
several hundreds of thousands of
entities if you have several dozens or
several hundreds entities then you
typically end up with very well-behaved
or effects from this reason in the
process now what have you seen you have
seen the user side of it use a site
getting feedback you've seen the person
at this software development company
specifying a demain specific language
also he is getting feedback about well
this language is consistent in itself as
well the user is getting feedback but
how can you do that how can you specify
this language well for this purpose for
this case we have developed an
integrated meta meta model so to bridge
between the two pillars of down on
underwear on the one side and the
software development bots on the other
side there is now this integrated meta
meta model that allows you to
instantiate entities which belong to the
ontology space as well as to
normal for example uml modeling space so
with using these modeling constructs you
can at the same time doing your kind of
normal modeling process as well as
benefit from the reasoning process to
the extent that the reasoner supports
this and what you see here is on the
left side is the reasoning process with
the two levels tee box in a box they are
called you can query there the
ontological structures and reason about
them and on the right side you have all
the tools that you would typically use
in a model-driven software engineer now
the nice thing about this and that was a
nice part of this cooperation in the
project that then the project partners
at kamoj they also looked into whether
this would be of any help to the people
that would use this framework so they
looked at productivity they looked at
quality and they looked especially in
the first place now at the dsl designers
how difficult is it for these designers
to develop such a domain-specific
language and then get some feedback and
of course the assumption was that you
want have language without errors
without mistakes so of course you have
to also measure the box that you prove
that you produce them so now the nice
figures for us that they came up with
was they looked at how did people do it
before because they have this already is
part of the process and what happens
once you include the ethology reasoning
technology into this game and what you
see here is a productivity improvement
of thirty percent and the quality
improvement of almost fifty percent and
maybe offline i can give you more
details about this work exactly and run
a little bit short of time to go also
into process reasoning with ontology
technologies here the idea was basically
and that was an case study with sapa-ap
has several stages of development and
here i try to set this apart between
Dilbert and his manager the manager says
well we need a process that says select
applicant and hire him and then the
developer comes up as well it's not
exactly
how the process works but of course the
question in the end of the day is
whether what is developed still
corresponds to this high-level
specification and then SI p they have
three to four layers of specifying how
this process works exactly now at the
end of the day you may ask is what you
have on the right side still the thing
that you wanted to have from your
business point of view on the left side
and we do some ontology reasoning for
this in order to answer this question
here I jump a little bit here what you
need is a different kind of bridge you
don't need a bridge way of a joint
metamodel between these two different
areas what you need is a transformation
bridge where you compile this here it's
bpmn processes into a told you recently
technologies and then do the reasoning
and deliver the corresponding results
here do a little bit fast forward that
because they jump directly again to the
evaluation that colleagues it as a
period they looked at some of the normal
cases they have from their development
lifecycle and then looked at the how
difficult it was for people to find the
problems and to repair these problems
and gave this challenge to different
people people within as AP people within
our project and also looked at how these
would behave differently actually it was
similarly difficult or simple you could
say for each of these different groups
of people to come up with the correct
answers but if you compare the different
technologies without the support or with
the support indicated here in both this
red arrow then they came up with some
numbers about savings of productivity or
quality improvements and again we are in
range that makes it really worth it to
look at this process using these
reasoning technologies so what I try to
indicate here was that by including
these ontology reasoning technologies up
by building bridges between these two
areas and I shown you here to breeches
one bridge was an integration bridge
where we would have a joint metamodel
that would allow you to go into two
different pillars in order to do what
you want to do there independently
and the other one was a transformation
bridge and they would compile some model
aspect into the reasoning representation
in order to come up with the problems
that you find there and you can do this
at different layers and use this as
different players at the m3 layer
following the the normal OMG
nomenclature or at the m2 layer each
time you can look at what does it help
me to do this transformation or this
integration and you have seen some of
these cases like the configuration case
there are other cases we have looked at
in this project and for example here the
Allies a case would transfer normal your
male model into ontology reason in order
to check the problems that come up in
this normal model so what is a takeaway
message for you well we had a couple of
original contributions here which was
about these to build of pillars which
came in the beginning from quite a
different and namely from the end of
this frustration of having to somehow
linked these two different worlds by
linking these two different worlds what
we saw was that it's not just convenient
for ontology applications it is too but
it's also convenient for normal type of
applications where no real anthologies
in the original sense are really
participating and we have looked at here
at the main specific languages and
process languages the marriage is not
quite trivial and we still learn how to
do it and we look at other cases we'll
look at cases where reasoning is not
only spanning two and levels but three
levels of reasoning there are
technological problems I told you about
this problem calling in the open world
the closed world that's the logicians to
and that always gives trouble to
software engineers and database people
because well the database persons
typically talk about closed worlds but
once you find the right terminal
terminology like this is a model that's
currently drafted and business model
it's really finalized and should be
finished and
and no further mistake or problems
should be in there then people start to
understand what this technology is doing
for them and finding these translations
is important you can see some
productivity gains and if I have to look
forward what I see and what I try to
generalize here is that these are the
ontology is in the original sense they
contribute some knowledge by the domain
experts because these ontologies are
typically not built by software
engineers the FMA has been built by
doctors the gene ontology is built by
people in this bioinformatics to me so
they contribute knowledge about their
domain not using that I think is a lost
opportunity when you include it there
are so many ways you can do it and we're
still figuring it out we're playing rod
for example with families of business
processes with reporting a paper on that
you're playing around with software
product lines where this domain
knowledge is important and that seems
quite useful to have there we think that
these terminologies should be reused and
when we look at different software
components different software projects
what we also see is then it's not just
that we have this knowledge confined
within one project but typically you
have many projects that run next to each
other and in the end should play
together and you quite often they don't
but capturing knowledge about how they
could or should play together is one of
the task you want to tackle and we think
that semantic technologies ontologies
and semantic web form is like refr the
right answers to respond to these needs
and here are some references of our own
work also to some work by other people
and thank you for your attention thank
you
so we have time yeah yeah thank you for
your talk I'm Gregory Engels una volta
para bond I can understand that you can
help us as software engineer on the
structural side but the bigger problem
in our domain of software engineering is
how to use this behavior this means how
to deal with dynamic things and I can
understand that you can help me that I
builds a white object diagram but this
is not not so difficult for me talking
myself engineers you can except my
question is is it also any can you say
something about the future how you also
can help on the dynamic side so I second
question before I do my Michael the
second one is that in the second example
you spoke about these transformations I
missed the word semantics because you
are changing the language from one side
to the other side and what is about
semantics ok very good questions first
about the first question was about to
prob out can we do more than structural
diagrams more than let's say you have a
class diagrams yes we can but to some
extent we can only do structural
analysis on other models so for example
we looked at PP mm and we did structural
analysis on these models and then this
cave has already quite some feedback
about what was prom attic in this models
and people that sa p also compare this
to pedro nets analysis for example with
some ups and downs for both these two
technologies can we do really reasoning
with state changes no that's outside the
realm of description logics reasoning
well maybe people come up with other
kinds of neat integration of let's say
some semana logic with parts of
description logics in the future I don't
know would be a good research question
probably and would still maybe to some
extent this could still be even
pragmatically
you know cover something i don't know
this really speculating but right now i
would say no you cannot describe state
changes what you can do you can describe
structural aspects of dynamic behavior
when you look at then the other question
about what happens with these
transformations one interesting
questions i think is that you have this
process is that we could also describe
structurally in description logics what
i would like to include there with these
processes are also the terminologies we
didn't do this until now but actually
that's one thing that i would like to do
to say i have different process steps
and for example if we merge two
companies then well the one company had
one way of calling their process steps
and the other company had another way of
calling them and you could at the same
time look at these processes
structurally and look at their
terminology and then look at what does
this give us if we combine these
descriptions of behavioral aspects it's
not everything but i think that would be
quite interesting research activity to
perform i think that was it okay my
question r is somehow related to the
previous question and it is also related
to our my previous work on our
multilingual generation multilingual
mitchell language generation so that are
the idea was that you have a formal
specification of software and from this
formal specification di if you have the
right grammar you can generate of the
user manual for this software in so many
languages right and the problem in this
case r is that any formal specification
of software it misses one part which is
most crucial for the user manual and
this is a plan for operations so in
order to do this you need our to
implement a sequence of steps right and
are just just my question is about the
way of on the one hand of getting this
out of the formal specification and I
would do think about the possibility of
representing this in
terms of you're a boxes I think that
that that that that something to this
extent was in your presentation you skip
to ever in your experience with SI p but
but i'm not sure i'm i'm not sure I
understand the question I mean what you
seem to suggest to me is that you have
some approach like either literate
programming or you have these models and
you try to automatically generate the
natural language that we come close to
some literate programming from these
descriptions I must say the idea is
around for example in the ontology area
to describe anthologies with natural
language I have not seen a convincing
solution for this problem until now it
would be good to have such a convincing
solution because people have problems
looking at these anthologies these form
structures and understanding what they
mean so it's still an unsolved problem
and I think the problem is even more
difficult if you consider software
modeling in general well let's thank our
speaker again and I would love to
continue conversation but we need to
break for the afternoon break if you are
still interested in learning more about
making sense of the sense of data there
is another session tomorrow morning
thank you